oh well you know it was in all kinds of
forms other than those too I mean it
started out like really like a band you
know in rock clubs and was in a more of
a cabaret setting it was in a sort of
pseudo cabaret theater setting than it
was in a theater then it was a film it's
been in concert you know which is the
only a whole different thing we're
preparing to have it on Broadway which
will be it different so to me I don't I
don't differentiate them by in terms of
you know one six more successful than
the other they all have their challenges
they are the rewards and to me they're
complementary so I just enjoyed being
able to to try in different in different
venues and also enjoyed seeing other
people do it as well I was I'm never
micromanaging about other productions
you know some people get very uptight
about protecting their property and it
can only be done this way to me that
kind of kills it makes it a museum piece
well you know it was really my composure
and I I mean from the beginning but I
was playing around with some ideas and I
knew I wanted to make a rock theatre
piece with the Pilatus story of the
origin of love as the central metaphor
and and met with a few composers and
then Stephen Trask the songwriter came
on and we really developed it for many
years together so bits and pieces of
both of our lives came came through his
struggling music career my growing up in
the army bases it's not really
autobiographical story in terms of facts
but it's definitely emotionally out of a
biographical moving around a lot as a
kid and my father being the military
commander of Berlin before the wall came
down and there was a you know there was
a woman who was our babysitter a german
divorcee living in a trailer park
who was my my brother's babysitter and a
prostitute on the side and I didn't
really clock that to later but she was
the original inspiration for advic and
then you know other characters in my
life were grafted on her but you know
probably heard her aesthetic came from
other people but her emotional core just
came from my own you know sort of
feeling a citizen of the world kind of
seeking out in her you know interaction
and connection in a chaotic kind of you
know sort of
I don't know what to call it I guess the
kind of understanding that we're all
very much these hybrids of all the
people that we've met you know and men
women lovers mothers fathers and
reinterpreting the myth of the origin of
love as a kind of collage of all the
people we know rather than just two
halves so you know it's still something
that that the my interpretation of
changes you know when I look at it as I
age
you know I don't know yet because I
haven't really you know entered that
realm yet I it's interesting to think
about in terms of writing and directing
but I really don't know till I get there
but it's a kind of an ageless character
could be you know she really could be
telling her story at any given time you
know in her life and you know I could be
doing it in a wheelchair at some point
but there's see